for
e
uh good evening
everyone welcome to November's meeting
of the scrutiny panel uh run through
health and safety fire alarm procedures
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices down the main stairs
opposite the in the foyer assemble in h
Square on the green officers will assist
you and advise you when it's deemed safe
to return to the chamber uh would
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they are not used to make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
uh please note that this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public uh the meeting is also being
recorded and will subsequently be
broadcast on the internet uh does anyone
intend to film the
meeting no and we got no members of the
public so we'll move on from
that
I've had no request to speak under 20.1
and no members of the public so uh we
move on to apologies for absence I've
got councelor faruki substituted by
councelor Boyd councelor Austin
substituted by councelor Garner and
councelor Moore substituted by councelor
town and are there any more apologies
councelor Curry uh apologies from uh
councelor
Deo thank you councelor Curry uh I've
had one Declaration of interest uh from
councelor Pacman on item number nine so
we'll address that when we get to that
uh okay moving on to item three the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting to
approve the minutes of the extraordinary
overview and scrutiny panel meeting held
on the 19th of September uh copy is
attached to the agenda pack uh can I
have a proposed
please councilor Brer and a second up
councelor Davis and all members
agree thank you uh moving on to item
number four to approve the minutes of
the overview and scrutiny panel meeting
on the 26th of September uh 20 23 a copy
is attached to the agenda pack can I
have a
proposal count councilor Bry sorry at
the um item number 479 just a question
um we uh Council Austin proposed and
councilor question bright SEC that
leveling up fund and town deal projects
updates be presented at all future uh
meetings I guess in the form of a ganta
um I don't see that in the pack do we
have a a reason for
that uh I'd like to give you a reason I
have requested it a couple of times I
haven't had a response from the director
whether we're going to get one or not I
know I've spoken to councel Austin who
proposed that last time um she's now
sent an email copy me into it today uh
to councilor ever for him to take it up
so hopefully we'll get one next time but
I haven't even had a response from the
director I will take that up as well
with the leader thank you thank you uh
can have a second councelor Davis sorry
councelor green proposed uh Council
Davis second do all members
agree just one item from that as well
Council Davis you proposed um that
presentation that we had with ceiling
and so that's one uh thing we got out
for that okay moving on to item five the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting uh
to approved the minutes of the
extraordinary overview and scrutiny
panel meeting held on the 24th of
October a copy the chat the agenda pack
can I have a proposer Council Curry and
second that councelor cup and all
members
agree okay it's moving on to item number
six the cabinet member presentation uh
the TDC policy regarding broken bins and
I've added in because I had a member uh
contact me about an issue he thought
there was with the green bin renewal
policy although that member hasn't come
along this evening certainly um so I
added that in so I didn't want to call
counselor album back again for a second
time so we decided to add it together
and I'll count call look on Council
alurn to give his presentation which I
think you're going to do one at a time
so thank you yeah thank you chair um I
can't think of a better way to spend a
Tuesday evening than to discuss uh
broken bins chair I think it's a but
it's it's something that our our
residents are concerned about and um so
um what I want to do is to uh take you
through some
um views that you'll see in relation to
uh what the overall View of how we deal
with the uh the bins the state of the
bins and how many we do so if uh I can
ask for that's it thank you very much
background um as you can see that the
waste team uh currently collects from
over 70,000 properties throughout
thanet 57,000 of these properties are
classed as curbside Collections and as
such will have some form of container uh
most most commonly a 240 240 L beans um
with differing lid colors as as we all
know uh black for refu blue for mix uh
maybe red bags or red or red um ly bins
for paper and brown uh for garden
waste um over the course of a
fortnightly collection cycle our cruise
collects over
250,000 of these
containers we currently operate two
delivery teams that that consist of a
sole
driver right um in the past 12 months we
have received
6,639 reports of damaged bins uh wheed
Bin that's wheeled
bins
2,971 which is 45% from the public buau
call center or
3,668
55% from our staff through the bch
system and for those of you who don't
know the bch system is situated within
the cab of the uh waste trucks uh and
they record everything that happens uh
on that on their
round uh other services will be
prioritized if we are short staffed uh a
bins are delivered Monday to Friday to
meet overall delivery demand uh new Bins
other bins bags they have have about 35
to 45 uh jobs per
day um lead time for that is
approximately four to 5
weeks over the last two years £
46,7 has been spent on
bins
186,000 and a half th000 uh in 2022 23
and
220,000 in 2324 and that's the year to
date uh at the cost of £1
19995 a bin bin budget for the period is
$296,500 and there is
0,90 overspend to
date okay next
one um in
theory uh wheels and Lids can be
replaced although isn't as easy as it
would seem
they are made to last so removing and
reattaching parts is time consuming and
roughly about 5 to 10 minutes and um I
think if you see the amount of return or
broke broken beans that if you add that
up with 5 to 10 minutes that's quite an
amount of time um bins also change shape
over the time meaning that new parts may
not fit what I mean by by that is that
um obviously there being plastic uh they
expand in the
summer uh and uh retract in the winter
and of course the that that ends up with
a different temperatures and they
split but just to give you an idea of
that um generally all from one company
but they have changed style slightly too
so there's different styles of bins of
which the lids will not fit other
bins um bins are currently not repaired
due to the issues outlined and time
constraint
due to the sheer volume of request and
staff
availability uh broken bin broken bins
recycled into pellets and they are used
to make more bins so it's fully re
recyclable as far as that
goes um okay repair versus replace um
not all damage to bins can be repaired
um the only thing that can be repaired
uh will be damaged to the lid or to the
wheels the body and the lip of the bin
are not repairable the lip is the bit
that goes onto the onto the back of the
trap for it to be tipped in lid opens up
and then it
empties repairing a broken lid or Wheels
is a lower cost than a full replacement
but does not lengthen the working life
of the bin the additional time taken to
repair a bin would potentially mean the
need to to uh employ an additional crew
and vehicle to meet
demand so in summary um bins will get
broken through a variety of
ways um ultimately we need residents to
have containers for health and safety
reasons environmental factors and
eventually for managing waste disposal
be behavior and encouraging
recycling bin Replacements result in an
overspend against the annual
budget current method of dealing with
the issue is just a is uh for example is
just replacing them is the most
efficient and coste effective way of
addressing the
issue um I think if if if you think
uh to come off uh line from from this
just just for a second so if we repair
Mrs uh Smith's lid she gets her old bin
back uh with an old lid um it won't last
and it's just as
uh it's just as good to replace the bin
rather than to repair it and the same
goes for the wheels as well
um so pushing back where we don't
believe we are responsible for bin
damage up cycling of beans uh for
alternative
uses so that's that's that on on on that
issue if you're all right chair I'll
just go through the garden waste unless
you want to take do questions on that
first uh I think I'll ask members if
they want to address that absolutely
members that's a subject that you wanted
me to pick up so over to you councelor
co uh yeah I think probably best if we
concentrate on the the the black bin and
the blue beins rather than the green
waste yeah so um just um a question uh I
understand that the council um are not
really in favor of repairing the bins
and I you know I've heard the reasons
given um can I ask if residents do phone
in uh to say that they been has been
damaged during the collection do they
receive um a bin free of
charge
yeah thank you chair um uh the short
answer is yes so if they have proof that
the bin has been damaged uh when it goes
loaded into the truck um maybe the lid
comes off because it does happen uh then
then they will get a bin free of
charge Council
wi sorry Steve I've got three questions
so 1995 is the cost per bin is that what
we pay uh and if that's what we pay what
is the actual cost a resident for
replacement I've got three questions so
I'll I'll I'll do a question and then SE
an answer if that's
okay sorry if I could just ask uh Mr
Elmer if he'll come in on that that' be
a lot easier thank you yeah sure so that
is what we pay 1995 it's working across
um other accounts stuff that's a good
price for it that's about the the going
rate um we currently don't charge
residents for broken bins when they're
replaced what what do we charge
residents if it's not broken they just a
new one it's
lost um I'll have to come back to you
counselor if that's right to give you
the up toate I've got some cost here but
then but then but then then they're not
the up to- date one so if I can just
come back to you on that but we do but
it is I can confirm it is more than 1995
because that's
the price we pay for the purchase of the
bin it doesn't
include the cost of you know unpacking
it delivering it those S things so
there's a cost for transport on those
things also you you mentioned broken
bins are recycled into pellets to make
more bins how many do we recycle each
year uh I can't answer that
so in terms of numbers again I've not
got the number in front of me basically
what we do is the broken ones are stored
either here or there is a storage plac
down at the Port when there's enough to
have a full
load just for sheer economies and so
we're not paying for any empty space in
terms of Transit then a full load goes
yes it be good it would be good to have
that information going forward uh the
other thing is how many broke I haven't
been to the
Margate recycling center for for some
time I would imagine several years but
the last time I was there there were
black bins it was like a black bin
graveyard they were stacked uh piled
high I'm hoping they're still they've
been removed but how do we presently
have bins stored at at the Margate Depo
broken bins the the bin gave graveyard
and how many would you estimate that are
there so just to also just follow up on
your previous question
when we collect bins that are broken
they are recycled so they they the bin
lid is taken off the wheels are taken
off they are stacked and then a company
removes them for recycling so we don't
dispose of them in any other way that's
the that's the method of the disposing
of them um I can't tell you exactly how
many are there now but um as uh Matthew
has said we they build up and then we um
you know spend some time with staff
stripping them down um stacking them up
ready for ready for removal so there
isn't a continuous uh process of of
breaking them down as they come in you
you you know we wait until there is a
number of them where it's worth spending
a week of of Staff time doing that piece
of work and then getting rid of them so
my last question is and you've sort of
partly answered it you've led me right
down the path I wanted to go is there is
an environmental cost and we have
declared climate emergency and we
already take the bins to bit has just
been confirmed by Mr Humber uh so what
happens if I'm a resident who has a
black bin I don't I have a seagull sack
and I want a new I I'm quite happy to
have a secondhand lid because I've
decided I'm never going to buy anything
new again can I ring the council and go
and collect one from the tip and mend my
own bin which would seem a very good
pilot for us to undertake cuz the bins
are already been stripped down and
obviously the other the cost of putting
the bin together would just be the
resident actually doing it
themselves uh I'll answer that one chair
um the answer is no they can't come onto
the site uh because of health and safety
um otherwise we'd have public coming up
on the site all day and we can't do that
there's so many lry movements etc etc
and they can't do it on under health and
safety grounds I understand what you're
saying and it would be ideal but we're
not a we're not a you know a guard
shared workshop for people to come up
and Fiddle about and fix their own bin
uh we can't do that it's it's it's
working environment and we just can't do
that and and if I just for a second if I
can Mr Sanam says he can advise us to
what the price of a bin to the public is
so obviously it depends on the size of
the bin but a standard container is £
4455 currently and the larger container
is £ 5731 and that includes the cost of
admin and delivery and everything else
so I mean I will come back at this
because I can buy the bits for my broken
bin on the internet and we've got a
whole store of broken bits and I think
it's worth pursuing some sort of pilot
where we could send the bits out or a
space a safe space where people could
collect the bits cuz I certainly
wouldn't want a sort of 100% increase in
purchasing a new bin uh from a counil
that I already pay my rates to I could
understand paying for the you know the
the cost of the bin in fact I'm sure I
can buy one online for cheaper than than
40 than 440 so I I definitely feel we've
declared a climate emergency that's
really great that we're recycling we're
already taking the bins to bits and we
should be trying to pursue some sort of
upcycling of our broken
bins can I come back on that chair yes
sure thank you in a perfect world
councel wing it would be wonderful thing
to actually do but we're not in a
perfect world we got to live within the
budget that we've got and we got to deal
with that um and to and so you know the
likelihood of that happening is rare
let's put it like
that councelor
Davis thank you chair um while we were
looking at the presentation on
performance something jumped out at me
particularly which is that in the whole
of
2223 we had a a budget of 1865 thousand
and yet year to date we're only 6 months
in
give or take and we've got a 20%
increase to 220 so far um I wondered why
that might
be I'll ask Mr Humber if he can advise
you at that councelor Davis thank
you yeah certainly um so the spend isn't
linear is the first thing when we
purchase bins we purchase a large number
at a time so the spend isn't isn't a
isn't a linear thing we we buy thousands
of at a time so we spent you we there's
a large purchase price um I think it's
worth saying that although theough the
slide shows an an overspend that
overspend is part of the budget
monitoring process and it's managed
within within the budget so we we move
money around between budgets to make
sure that we cover those spends um that
said last year there is there was an
overspending on the service and this
year if you look at the you know I know
the the quarter 2 is um budget
monitoring is on the on the agenda here
you there is currently a predicted
overspend for for cleansing services so
there is there is um overspending in the
service but I think in response to that
it's it's it's not a linear we don't
spend you know a certain amount each
month every month it it depends on when
the purchases are
made so so to clarify how often would
these purchases be made obviously if
they're not linear then the frequency
those dictates our value against against
that delineated time roughly how often
do we have orders going in for them cuz
I mean it's an amazing figure that's 130
bins a week being
broken I think I can come back with that
detail we we we'll check that detail on
how often they are if you want if you
want an accurate answer I think that's
the best thing to do thank you cuz I
think that's key to actually you know
looking at the the value judgment on
this matter and obviously the very real
environmental impact to keep buying
plastic thank you councelor
cup uh thank you chair and thank you for
the presentation most enjoyable about
bins thank you um my question is related
to the I suppose the um the broken being
pandemic in a way across the country
have we looked at other councils in how
they areal dealing with this issue how
um how many brok and beans are happening
in other districts and authorities as
well um and we say that the price that
we pays is a good price is that because
they are um lower down in the tier of
how robust they are hence why we're
getting so many broken bins and would it
be worthwhile then looking at spending a
little bit more on on the bin to ensure
that then they're less likely to be uh
flimsy and to have a longer lasting life
thank you
yeah um I think uh I think was said
there the average the average lifespan
of any plastic bin that's out in the
weather all year round uh rain wind
shine Frost snow whatever um is roughly
about on average about 8 to 10 years um
so yes there are a number of there are
number 130 as councilor Davis has said
but again when you when you equate that
to uh 70,000
properties uh across the island and and
the trucks going out every day and the
uh the bashing really that they do take
um you know there are some people are
very nice with their bins and wash them
and clean them and do and love them um
but then there are a lot a lot of people
who don't and I think that's the other
that's that's the issue they don't care
um
so I can't answer councelor cup
in relation to uh whether our officers
have been looking at other councils as
to as to what they buy how they buy cuz
a lot of counts are different you
couldn't compare us with uh tambridge
Wills for instance you know they haven't
got the uh they haven't got that tight
capacity uh within the town centers that
we got in in Ramsgate and brers ET C Etc
you know uh different a little bit
different in burington some places in
broadstairs where you've got the uh the
Bungalows etc etc and they are they are
easier because you got less people there
less people living in a property where
you've got multiple occupancies and
stuff like that the bins are stuffed to
capacity and sticking out of them so
they do bows they do what so whilst
there is a lot of Bin
Replacements it's it's how they're dealt
with and uh but we have to deal with
that and the main thing is to keep the
service going thank you chair councilor
town
in yeah sorry if if I could just add add
to that as well that our bins are mainly
from one manufacturer and it's one of
the market leaders so they are I would
say you know a good quality bin um but
as as Council Aubin has said it's about
the the service life of them and the and
the the abuse they get but also that um
at the rate at which we're replacing
them we're we're asking them to last
longer than that 8 to 10 years and
that's where why we need to invest and
we have increased the amount of money we
spend on replacement bins because they
do get to a point where if the lip
breaks it becomes a a you know a health
and safety issue and that to be honest
is another reason why if we repair bins
then we we're replacing the lid or we're
replacing the wheels but we're not
replacing the body and it's the bin body
when it splits and becomes damaged that
we you get start to increase that health
and safety issue that the bin could
potentially drop from the bin lift
mechanism on the back of the vehicle
which is obviously is a problem because
they're quite big and heavy so
um replacement is you know the frequency
of replacement is an issue that we we
need to keep on top of and and and it's
a it's an issue that goes you know is is
assisted by replacing the bin rather
than repairing the
bin Council
turn couple of things
um 1995 is not a lot of money for a bin
as far as I can see uh have you ever
worked out actually um what it costs to
actually repair these bins against just
saying well we're not going to repair
we're just going to recycle and move on
and replace it with a new bin because
what I can see is we're taking parts
from all over the place and putting them
on you know damaged bins to put them
back up into
circulation and the other thing is um so
have we ever worked that out you know
the two things the other thing is how
many bins do we have we charged people
to replace you know the 50 OD quid that
Matt has just mentioned U do you know
the figures on that in the year how much
we actually earn out of that or how many
we do uh yeah I'll just I'll just answer
uh Council tanning on his um on on his
first part about the
um replacing and re redoing the bins I
think that without wanting to go over
the same old the same old Mantra but
um if the
council would decide to give us more
resources more money to get more staff
so we could have them sitting in the the
Manon Road Depot repairing bins um a bit
like Santa's little h
um then I'm sure that you know that that
we could do the recycling of those but I
think you got to have you got to take on
board is is the fact that it's not uh
comparable in currently in offic of time
and uh because we need them to do things
that are that our residents require most
which is emptying their bins and
ensuring that that the rounds get done
um
rather than sitting in uh sitting in the
U mxon Road Depot repairing a couple of
Lids um so
um as far as the other bit about how
many broken beads I can't give the
answer to that have you maybe Mr Elma
might be able yeah it's quite a simple
answer we haven't charged any residents
from you ever thought of getting a
volunteer team to repair bill
you know uh which might be not a bad
idea you know some retired guys I'm not
retired yet unfortunately but uh well
that's a shame cuz I'd have asked you'd
have been the first person I'd have
asked Council town in to come down to
the manston road Depot get your some
still toeat boots and a nice white hat
and we'll see sit you in a corner and uh
repair the beans for us and we would
love that so um we'll we'll we'll see we
we will look at that Council tning thank
you
got your your your name written over it
s uh councelor
Bri um yeah I hope I'm not asking a
question that's already been asked I
don't think I have
um are we I'm I'm slightly bothered by
the fact that it's all it all ends up in
sort of overspend so when did we first
introduce uh like solid black bins
plastic bins so is this kind of like
wave two of the 8 to 10 year life cycle
and is this something we can start
thinking about maybe in I don't know 5
10 years time do we need to start
planning a little bit more so that we
can we might get this because I think I
wonder if to Council of Cups point about
the the pandemic of broken bins that
this is because basically councils up
and down the land shifted from either
just bin bags to to from and metal bins
to plastic bag plastic bins around about
the same time thank you chair I can't
really answer that um but
um just so probably whe you might know
you might not know but the government
were looking at at um ensuring that all
councils have the
same so if that was to take place I know
I think they put on the back burner for
now I think they got other things that
we worried about in the moment um but um
that was to be that all bins would be
the same at every Council so we would
have to replace the whole lot so uh
knowing whatever government's inair they
wouldn't give a full amount then we
would have to find that money from
somewhere um but uh I'll refer back to
you Mike if that's okay you're right on
that thank you yeah thank you councelor
Orin
um yeah I think there's not much to
expand on
a on that um you're right the
environment act um
includes uh part environment about waste
standardization so the container stand
is standard is standardized
nationally um I know that that's been
pushed back def have pushed back um the
the dates for some of the work around
the actions from the environment act um
but yet our current bin um you know the
arrangement the the current collection
method came out in about
2012 and so yes you're right that you
know bins have a finite life but that's
why we are increas or have over the last
three is increase the amount of money uh
available for the replacement of bins so
for for replacing damage bins um and you
know obviously we'll continue that in
that
investment I'm Keen to move on just take
two more I was going to say cancel wing
and councel Davis mine's a quick one I'm
assuming we do charge some people for
bins that are not broken so people who
move into new new places new uh new
developments I don't mind ripping the
developers off that's fine charge them
more than 50 but what do we do with the
uh what do we do with the extra cost um
I would love for it to come back into
waste and recycling team so that we can
make other things happen outside of our
normal
budget I think that's a Mr Sanam
question
is so effectively in relation to new new
developments at the moment so we do
charge on an ad hoc basis there'll be a
few people that obviously say they don't
want a red bag anymore can they have a
red bin that's chargeable at the moment
so they pay for that so to date there's
over 30k that's being received in
relation to income from Mostly new
developments that is used to offset the
additional cost of bins across so that
it reduces the impact on service so it
is it does directly go into cleansing
services to offset that impact so the
net impact this year if you're talking
about 100 odd Grand overspend is part of
that is offset by that
income C
Davis I've been incredibly quick but my
question and you probably won't have the
answer to hand but but but is what is
the ratio between uh bust bins of the
smaller capacity and the larger because
as has been mentioned the ones we see
broken are often overflowing and it's
because they've been
rammed if there's no great cost
implication um so so where my question
would lead is perhaps I could recommend
looking at if there's no great cost
implication just sticking with the
larger size bin at as a standard and on
that basis it you know the because it is
the smaller households I've I've noticed
that often have and along com someone
else it only needs one bag round in and
Bob junle the bigger bins do seem to
mitigate that just a thought and just to
finish because we are on bingate I know
but floppy horriable seao bags do we
have a a budget for loss on those how do
they Faire are they a problem other than
in the in terms of existence
yeah well um I think uh Mr Hamber answer
your first question councel Davis um on
the on the Sea gold bin uh bags I mean
they're not the nicest of things to to
have for any uh
resident um they are used especially
like in Ramsgate a lot um where there's
a lot of multiple occupancies or
properties been converted into SE
several flats and the issues that we do
have um are
the people leave the bags out uh they
leave them on the on the railings and
everything that it's not the nicest of
it's not the nicest of VI but then again
you have to understand that people don't
want a dirty great big bag with a load
of rubbish in uh stinking their stinking
their particular flat out until it's
time for them to be collected um I don't
think we have that many um replacement
bags coming out because normally they're
outside on the railings and they're
they're TI up to them and a full Up full
up of rubbish um but I would imagine
it's quite low but I haven't got any
figures on that for
you if yeah if perhaps if I can come
back on the first part of your question
counselor Davis um what we're always
trying to do is encourage recycling so
we're happy to provide you know a blue
bin and an extra blue bin if there's
lots of recycling going on at a property
what we don't want to do is increase the
size of black bins so they're always 180
and we would like them to be smaller and
going forward with the requirements of
the environment act which will make it
compulsory to to recycle things like
food waste and and there'll be other
waste streams coming on that black bin
needs to get smaller because that's the
way that we will drive the percentage of
recycling up by stopping people having
the choice and what we know now when we
do um analysis of of what is in the
black bin some of that can be recycled
and it and and it's about changing that
behavior and one of the ways of doing
that is to reduce the size of the black
bin not just in thanet nationally so
that we encourage that uh that recycling
action was that a quick one
Christian going to say that if you're
interested councilor Brit has just found
a website called binb butler. co.uk that
gives you the full
history okay so we're going to move on
so I mean who would have thought that
would be that interesting uh councilor
Elvin uh we're going to now look at the
uh green bin renewal policy for
households I mean if if you're happy uh
chair as there the member who decided
that they wanted to talk about this
isn't here I mean I um obviously I don't
know what they've done so this
presentation is purely put together as
to as to what we do effectively so as
you can see the service runs
fortnightly uh predominantly on two
vehicles uh this increases to three in
the summer uh from April the 1st to 31st
of March following
year it's a paid for service which uh
cost £
6750 for 20123
2024 um and provisionally uh 7150 for
2425 that's that will be being put into
the uh the budget and Etc which probably
be looking at later um we currently have
12374 customers across
thanet uh we did 136 just over 136,000
successful collections last
year uh we had
1,77 reported misted
collections uh September the 22nd to
August 20 uh SE September 22nd September
22 to August 23 uh we collected 4,200 41
tons uh so it's quite a large
amount uh this is near the capacity for
the current deployed resource so in
other words for the amount of staff that
we have to be able to do this which then
would not affect other
collections um we're near enough
capacity for how much that we can take
on um renewals are sent out in February
and a reminder in March prior to the
renewal date um there are no direct
debit options to make process in the
renewal payments
simpler uh and that's that's all I've
got for you as I wasn't sure what you
what you wanted chair thank you no
that's fine I think the issue he had was
there was something to do with the the
the opening date for payment and the
closing date was very short and and I
think the the the direct debit option I
think was an issue for maybe someone
who's older I don't I don't that was
what it was but it's I hope councelor
war is watching and he's got his
question I could I mean I would say I
mean I would say chair we we are open to
to look in at that and to see whether
it's practical or not um so but uh you
know that suit we'll take on B chair and
and and have a look at thank you
councelor so members any questions
councelor brigh councelor Wing So This
is actually quite dear to my heart
because I lost my green bin after about
and not lost as in mislaid the the was
was withdrawn after about 10 years of of
of having it um my whole street and the
surrounding area we lost our round um I
believe the reason is because the the
the truck is slightly wider than the
standard truck is there any chance of
getting additional vehicles with an
additional spec or because I just think
we at the moment we are people are
putting leaves and green waste in
landfill they're taking it to the dump
or they're just putting it in their bins
and I don't think we should be you know
recycling or or binning leaves when it's
it's not particularly good for the
environment so I wonder if there's a a
future where I might be able to get my
green bin
back who's answering you yeah I just the
future is
green and um we are about to purchase if
uh a a new vehicle for
green uh I'm I do believe it's just got
a smaller wheel wheel base so it should
be able to get around the the smaller
streets making
Itor C councelor wi I yeah I think it's
over subscribed I I haven't got a green
bean because I've got no Garden
unfortunately but I do know several of
residents in central Harbor also had
their green beins removed from them some
of them really upset about it and some
of them elderly people who've got no way
of getting to the tip they don't have
they don't have transport uh and one was
told and undertook quite a battle with
TDC because they were told there was
access issues and this particular
address there are clearly no access
issues cuz it's right at the top of
elm's Avenue and the property just faces
you uh there's there's no there might be
access issues further down which H
hinders the round should we not be
looking at this as a growth area of of
an area that if if we can grow then then
we can pardon the P we can uh actually
make some money and and recycle recycle
that money back into the system and also
I mean I've been heavily involved in
removing large amounts of leaves from
from uh a place where where I work and
we put some of those leaves onto the
garden beds and leaves are uh provide uh
two two issues for some of the beds we
have a they are they suppress the weed
growth B they create an environment for
insects and there's the third one and C
they actually replenish nutrients into
the ground so should we not be looking
at growing this area and looking at
other ways of maybe distributing some of
the stuff the green waste that we
particularly leaves that our street
cleaners clear up and and and putting
those on some of our
beds yes thank you chair um I did
already say you know if the council
wants to give us more money uh then um
if you can persuade them to do that c
counselor Wing uh through the due
processes yeah then we can employ extra
staff and then we can emplo get an extra
vehicle and we can go around and we can
we can we can expand the delivery uh and
pickup process um but apart from that um
I'm sorry to hear about the the lady
that that you're talking about and I
would and I would
say get her to contact us she has no
well get to contact me then get to
contact me and uh and we'll see what we
can do thank you happy with that Council
Patman yeah thanks we talk about money
but just looking at the screen we make
about £800,000 a year on income what do
we do with
that uh we spend it on the
service
okay um
thanks councelor
Gana thanks yeah I'm I'm in I'm
interested to know actually what happens
to the the
4,241 tons of green waste that's
collected where does it go and and and
is it composted I assume it is composted
and then how is that compost made
available or used after after it's
compounded composted um I'll ask Mr Hur
be able to answer that
better yeah so um so all of our we're
the waste collection Authority um KCC
are the Waste Disposal Authority for
most of our waste streams so they go
they they go to a waste transfer site
for garden waste which is a
non-statutory part of the the service
that also goes to uh you know a waste
company and it is process so it is it is
um Garden waste is comp posted um what
they do with it after that is I mean
it's a you know it's a it's a commercial
commercial Enterprise so so that then
goes on to be used for for you for
commercial use composting use but but
yes that's that's what happens to it so
it doesn't you know it isn't um landfill
or anything like that yeah yeah I it's
worth saying that of all of our waste um
from thanet a very small amount of that
is landfilled most of it is either burnt
waste for energy or it's recy
cycled can I can I just yeah yeah I'm
sure I wasn't thinking it was landfill
up but we in another part of the council
there's a team that do a lot of
gardening not as much as they used to be
but still do a lot of gardening that I
assume use compost in in places or could
do we using compost I just want it this
isn't available to them I wonder you
know I was sort of wondering why can't
we have our own
Compost Facility on one of our sites
that we could collect waste that um
maybe not on the green bins here but we
can collect compostable material and
then recycle it and reuse it um in each
of the the Open Spaces team we use or
even make it available to sell there
lots of people want to buy
compost
um
yes in theory we could it's I mean that
that's a what you're talking about is a
capital project which would require
capital expenditure to to do it and
would require a a business case behind
it um um but but yes I mean it's it's
something that can be considered
yeah Council to yeah I I'm abely shocked
listening to council bright talking
about the fact that the lry doesn't go
up his his Road any longer we spent a
lot of money bu new B lores surely that
should have been taken into an account
to actually get a lry that would have
covered his needs or other people's
needs you know why on Earth didn't that
happen what was so wrong with our
thinking at the time could you tell us
please I'll try and answer that for you
councilor town and and and that is
normally as with any of their waste
Collections and including the the green
one waste uh if it's in small roads
narrow roads where there are Vehicles
parked either side the vehicles can't
get down it's as simple as
that yeah but now we're spending more
money to buy a vehicle to go down those
roads surely the cars are still parked
of that road so what's the difference
tell me the difference as you've heard
was is that it's got a smaller wheelbase
so where a normal truck you know you're
talking that that wheelbase is coming in
and they should be able to get down and
but even so if people Park on corners
and stuff like that it it would still be
a problem whether you've got uh small
even sometimes as you know we all know
fire engines ambulances can't get down
streets um so you know when it comes to
a waste truck whe whether it be normal
waste or or green waste sometimes there
are there are problems but we're hoping
replacing the old truck with a new truck
that that that one won't happen uh and
that we will we will be able to get
around in without any
problems other than that we'll just have
to get a hover one which goes over the
top of the cars we will try
that okay any further questions I cannot
just ask do do we make a surplus on the
uh the subscriptions or is that just to
cover the service or do we make a loss
or
so it it it goes back into the service I
think is the answer so um overall the
income and expenditure of cleansing
Services um needs to balance and it's
one of the it's one of the income areas
that helps to fund the
service so so I'm pretty sure did I not
hear a government policy that would
green waste would have to be a free
collection going
forward that was part of the environment
act but it's now been
removed okay all left to do thank
Council Al for coming along giving this
presentation and such an interest in
couple of subjects okay moving on thank
you chair can I just say thank you to
you chair and thank you to the members
for the for their questions thank you
very much excellent thank you right
moving on to item number seven the
budget monitoring 2023 24 report number
two uh and I call upon Matt sunam for
his
presentation presentation might be
overdoing it a little bit but yeah I
haven't got slides or anything so this
budget monitoring report provides the
2324 quarter 2 budget monitor position
for the general fund Capital forecast
against budget as well as housing
revenue account the key financial
messages contained within the report
with regards to the general fund are
that currently net spending is forecast
to be approximately 1.2 million pound
over budget which is largely due to an
anticipated overspend on temporary
accommodation for homelessness and a
shortfall against some of our income
streams as identified section two of the
report overspend is Not Unusual at this
time of the year and this does not raise
any serious concern concerns about the
finances as a whole all budgets will be
will continue to be regularly monitored
to ensure the council's expenditure
remains wherever possible within the
agreed budget the key financial messages
with regards to the housing revenue
account is that we are forecasting a 1.4
million pound Surplus against the budget
which is mainly due to better Returns on
our HRA investment balances and reduced
debt charges with regards to the capital
program the key message here is 6.5 and
6.6 of the report that there are some
recommended changes to the capital
program that were agreed by cabinet
included but not limited to increasing
the budget for disabled adaptations in
our residents home following the receipt
of additional external
funding thank you Mr members any
questions councilor
Davis um it's actually in budget monitor
report part two section 2.2 part three
to bring your attention cuz the Pages
aren't numbered so sorry if that sounds
convoluted however I'm a little bit
concerned that we're running on some
false expectations in certain areas
because this section refers to Maritime
and Technical Services and I'm going to
move across a couple of births from my
normal uh area of interest income is
projected
369,000 lower than budget expectations
within Port operations this is due to
restricted opportunities in part
stemming from a global shortage of Parts
um it's etc etc but to it refers to
income generated through car importation
and vehicle storage why are we expecting
anything to happen on that basis this
year when there haven't been any Car
Imports other than one year during the
pandemic when it was used as an over or
a backup
facility um I'm confused because we're
surely not project you know putting into
budget things that are then just sitting
and
hoping there is the port and harbor
budget within there there is uh
effectively an income Target for ad hoc
income that's generated as and when
through new opportunities in the past
part of that has been offset by um
opportunities with regards to car
importation and storage it's been offset
with things like um generator storage
it's being offset by things that we
don't normally base budget like the
jackup barge being in place so when
those opportunities don't arise or not
forthcoming which we obviously have no
control over it has the potential to
have an impact on the monitoring
position with regards to income however
should an opportunity arise during the
course of the Year through new
opportunities that would be used to
offset that income stream that has been
the case for probably the last five or
six years with regards well longer than
that actually with regards to the way
that that budget is represented within
the
reports thanks Matt this is very
interesting because maybe we're drilling
down to where we get told numbers work
differently on ports and in Ramsgate
when we when we've questioned the losses
in the past um I think I'd just like to
recall for the record that I think it's
quite incredible that we've got income
expectations based on potential windfall
and not on on any
um any firm projections so uh but thank
you thank you for clarifying that I
wouldn't say it's just based on windfall
every single Department within the
council that has an income stream
expectation will obviously suffer a
degree of risk based on market and that
has an impact at the moment for the port
and harbor that's represented by that
369 against their total income
allocations for the
year uh sorry that it's not the
principle that I'm questioning of that
and obviously that needs that needs to
be accounted and budgeted for in
expectations it's the fact that we're
using uh we're predicating and expecting
that budget to sort of and hoping it
will bring in things that are just not
NE well they're certainly not there um I
know that justifies that being in the
budget but that's what I'm a little bit
concerned about but thanks for
explaining that and it's something we'll
be looking into cheers that's Le uh it's
just that obviously homelessness has
really badly impacted and continues to
impact despite the fact we put
additional monies in uh first of all is
is it driven by a greater number of
homeless people appearing on our streets
or is it driven by an increase in
evictions or is it a combination of the
two it is effectively a combination of
this it's the perfect storm for
homelessness at the moment
it's all over the news isn't it in terms
of potential recent changes in terms of
legislation and stuff and and how that
is treated we are no different to any
other Council and I think for I think
Chris blondelle said this previously in
various presentations that he's done is
that for district councils homelessness
is the equivalent of social care because
it's a massive cost implication that we
have zero control over what what we have
done is we've put multiple things in
place to try and manage the impact of
that including the the current budget
proposals for next year are looking at
opportunities in relation to another
version of Foy house if you like so that
we can start continuing to control to
some extent the cost associated with
homelessness the problem is is it's
obviously we've put uh measures in place
early to try and mitigate the impact of
increased cost of homelessness and if we
hadn't have brought those forward into
22 23 which is what we did they would be
far more significant in 23 24 than they
are at the moment it's just every time
we put measures in place to deal with
with the impact as is something new
changes and the volumes increase
exponentially and we've got no control
over that am I right in thinking that
the main cost is is temporary
accommodation and and so our our our the
purchase of our own property will help
that to some extent but like you say the
problem then just gets bigger uh I would
like to thank the teams for doing all
they can cuz you know uh from from a w
counselor's point of view we we we are
seeing less people on the streets but
obviously there's a bigger problem so
our teams are doing all they can I just
wanted to ask about the port as well uh
do we have final costs for births four
or five so so I'm moving on from
homelessness to a homeless birth uh and
will there be any required
costs for I don't believe birth 45 is
operational and uh I do believe there
are some electrical work to do so do are
we coming to the end of the absolute
final spend on BST 45 and how how are
the ongoing issues with the bridge
impacting on on the uh on the cost of
the harbor uh trying to get that bridge
up and running because it's been several
years hasn't it to try and deal with
that
problem so to start with uh birth 45 it
so our works on the birth are complete
so that is um yeah the works finished
including the electrical work that's
finished and that's effectively now
available for use by Brett Aggregates um
the final account is not complete yet so
I can't report on that um and when it is
I'm I'm I'm sure we you we will do so
but that's still that's still uh not
complete um in terms of the bridge uh
yes the bridge um we're talking about
the bridge on the cross wall um was out
of service last year due to hydraulic
issues it was put back in service and
now it's out of service again while some
more repair Works uh go on uh the plan
for that is that it it will be back in
service before Christmas or very soon
after Christmas but we're hoping for it
to be back in service uh before
Christmas and in terms of the um the the
funding for that the work last year is
was was in part of last year's uh budget
but the work this this year where um the
plan is to um uh to recover that cost um
from the contractor who did the who did
The Works initially could I just ask
because we all know that there's a
conveyor that bretts may well put a
conveyor on that birth are is it are we
absolutely certain that there will be no
additional cost to us in locating that
conveyor onto that
pontoon going forward so that's that's
um for bretts it's it's their plant so
we provide the birth under the
facilities agreement and Brett's provide
the conveyor I don't want to stray too
far away from the agenda so you try and
keep to the
item simply to highlight the fact that
and funly enough it links to councelor
Wing's comment about conveyors um I'm
still questioning why we spent anything
on this because bretts were mored off of
the birth off of the uh key side the
other day discharging directly onto the
key so I think this is all worthy of
note but that's not as you said I won't
I won't distract but there are are
further issues okay so members any
further questions Mr s uh Council
Brer uh thank you chair um obviously
recently there's been the
announcement sorry yes mat um recently
has been the announcement that the uh
expected level of inflation has dropped
would that be would that have an effect
reducing the expected
overspend that' be minimal in simple
terms no it's because of the way the
budgets are built there's a certain
expectation in terms of what we will do
to mitigate the impact so every time we
build a budget we build in based on
inflation that we know at that time and
we obviously if it drops it's kind of
within the Realms of just managing those
budgets in totality there isn't even
though it's a significant drop in where
we are it's not below what our
assumptions were in relation to what the
average inflation would be for the
fourth coming year so therefore we end
up UT if you like there's no significant
savings as a as a result there is a
potential for cost avoidance because
obviously as inflation comes down some
of the costs that we were expecting to
exceed may not but not significant
enough to deliver savings if you
like no thank
you okay so uh Mr s's report has got to
go after to Cabinet do we have any
recommendations we'd like to
make no so if uh if none then we'll
we'll note the report thank you
okay moving on to item number eight the
adoption of a combined surveillance CCTV
stroke image recording Technologies
policy long I'll call on Mr gtis please
thank you chair I do promise to be brief
um CCTV and the use of image recording
is now common place across the country
from Town Center cctvs to building
Securities to cameras on dashboards or
dash cams ring doorbells and mobile
phones the council's use of CCTV is
governed by a profusion of legislation
codes of practice and central government
guidance new and emerging Technologies
and capabilities such as the increase in
artificial intelligence Biometrics or
advances in it system Integrations must
consider the increased risk to
individual rights and their privacies
and we must ensure that the council
continues to be compliant in its
activities in response the council has
developed to this policy which is
intended to regulate all the council's
operations and use of all image
recording systems across all areas of
the council the policy also introduces a
series of minimum standards as a guide
to all departments planning to procure
or utilize these types of Technologies
in the future thank
you thank you members any
questions oh councelor right sorry
not getting away with that one um so
once once we've once we've got uh
someone's image um regardless of whether
they're up to no good or not or we just
we just came where is it
stored um it stored digitally in the
CCTV control room um images are stored
for a maximum of 31 days unless used as
part of for evidential disclosure if
it's disclosed to um an investigate
agency such as police it's handed over
to them becomes their responsibility if
it's produced for them and not handed
over for any reason it's not collected
it's retained for a maximum of 90 days
and then
destroyed and once it is used is is
there is there a sort of trail that if
for example someone that looked like me
did something wrong and and and it kind
of went up the chain would I be able to
trace that data from yourselves onto the
police onto and know that it was it was
destroyed
yes thank you C
green uh if a department wants to to do
this process at what level of the
organization would they require
authorization from to do
it um thank you for your question that's
dependent upon the system and the
responsible manager the policy covers
different types of cameras and different
systems and different levels of
responsibility but ultimately all new
CCTV systems the CCTV service will have
to have line of sight of them to ensure
that they're suitable for use within the
district all right I'm I'm not sure does
that mean that Senior Management would
have to authorize it or or cabinet or or
or what
level um it once it's dependent upon the
level of the the procurement and the
level of spend so for a small system for
an office for example if it's
£30,000 the appropriate managers would
take that decision if it was for a large
system or a replacement of large system
you know something over the £250,000
threshold it would become in its own
right a key decision and would have to
come back
here it depends purely on cost not on
what the system's being used
for um the policy does cover the use of
system so what the systems intended
purpose for once again it's dependent
upon the different types of system there
is an audit Trail in place which is
written into the policy which allows
appropriate managers or the CCTV team to
have oversight and look that and to
ensure that camera's been used for its
intended
purpose councilor
Curry thanks chair and thanks for your
fast presentation
Eden um could you tell tell members do
we still have the temporary mobile
cctvs or are they all imp permanent
positions um yes we do have a number of
temporary CCTV cameras or redeploy bles
as we um refer to them they are coming
to the end of their life so as one comes
to the end of contracts currently we're
not replacing them what we are doing now
is we're tring a number of new providers
of redeployable CCTV systems and looking
at the policy the use of redeployable
CCTV is what we're going to be looking
at more into the future instead of the
use of fixed
systems thank you councilor Patman yeah
thanks chair um
so very quick question are CCTV manned
24 hours a
day no it records he Rec sorry um I'm
being flipping um the system records 24
hours a day currently the control room
when it's in operation is manned for 20
hours a day so there's nobody in the
control room between the hours of 5:00
a.m. and 9:00 a.m. when we looked at the
research and the available budget for
systems we looked at the number of
incidents that were covered in that time
frame that was the traditionally the
quietest time of the day for incidents
to occur and that's when we have nobody
in the control room but all the cameras
continue to undertake TOs and record
sorry so through you to come back um so
that's great so they are monitored out
of those hours out of those so I'm just
thinking of like Ramsgate on a Friday
night you know um they are being
monitored and police are in constant
contact with you guys to make sure that
they're deploying when there is trouble
um yes that's correct we do have access
to the police airwave system so we're in
direct contact with the police we also
have the ability to push the images that
we gather to the police control room as
well that's brilant thank you councelor
Wing I think you've answered my question
so do Can the police access our system
and I'm I'm assuming we can't access the
police system cuz it yeah having the
police get gaining access to as
many as as many CCT cameras across than
it helps
obviously um the police have access to
the cameras that we give them um but
that we also have a program that we're
developing to allow police offic
officers to undertake activities within
the control room within the environment
of the MTF we've started on a program to
train additional people to undertake
some of those monitoring activities as
to police themselves um they don't
routinely monitor their own cameras
anywh thank
you sh can I just make an offer to uh of
you scr me about uh visiting the uh
control room so if we set up some times
to do some tours of the control room uh
would members be interested in that I
can see lots of nodding heads so we'll
sort that out and uh and put something
in
place excellent Penny thank you uh
members any further
questions no okay so uh that report will
go off to cabinet and do we make any
recommendations uh councilor
green maybe I'm concerned unnecessarily
but I would like cabinet to look at the
authorization
process
so the Departments need to get authoriz
authorization to use these cameras which
are becoming increasingly powerful tools
and we don't want them springing up
everywhere without authorization and
recording where they are and what we're
using them
for okay do we have a policy on that P
that's exactly what this policy talks
about so um the the way the policy Lays
this out is that the cameras can't
spring up anywhere we have to follow the
codes of practice and the legislation
um in terms of sign off from cabinet on
every installation we do that's probably
a little bit over the top in terms of of
uh guidance but we can definitely talk
about having some Senior Management if
we need to but the policy clearly lays
out where cameras can be put in place
not anyone can access them I think
that's something we need to make quite
clear tonight they can only be
ACC accessed by authorized uh Personnel
so um it we can't allow anyone into the
room the room's locked and those that
can review it are the police um and then
often what happens is if a piece of CCTV
footage is required by somebody
internally if they have the
accreditation qualification they can
view it themselves if not the team
review the um footage for the time
period find the incident and then the
incident gets passed on to the the
people that require it so it's very
controlled in that respect but hope that
cover help a little bit Council green
that cover your not ready because what
I'm worried about is cameras being
installed for one purpose purpose and
then being used for another
by we we aren't allowed to do that so um
and and that's laid out quite clearly in
the policy um we are only allowed to
install
in areas where we have um a known need
um and I think what sorry Eden the
proportionality let Eden come in with
the exact
wording that there's there's an entire
commissioner set up for the usage of
CCTV and contend they've got 12 minimum
standards that they apply to us in
government authorities we have to
undertake a proportionality assessment
before we undertake any camera
installation in facts we we get requests
for cameras on a near weekly basis um
sometimes from elected members often
from members of the public can you
install the camera here we have to look
at a raft of different things we have to
look at crime rates we have to look at
the areas demographics we have to look
at any sort of requirements before we
can even consider installing any form of
CCTV system at all um to not do that
would be considered a breach of the
commissioner's codes of practice and
would mean that the district council is
liable the policy is specifically set up
to prohibit the introduction of new CCTV
on an ad hoc basis or in an area where
it's not
required does that answer your concern
David sorry but when you've done all
this who then
decides that that what you're proposing
is is proportional
and so that would that would come to
myself as head of service or to the
director to do that final sign
off would that be recorded who has made
that decision
yes okay so no recommendations to kavet
are we happy with
that I I I think it's a national policy
I don't think we we're doing our own
thing here I think it's there a national
standard that we all have to abide by
Council brigh so we had a we had a
situation in broadstairs where a CCTV
camera was damaged um and there was a
request from the the previous iteration
of the council to replace that but
actually it hasn't been replaced because
exact because of the the policy that uh
that pen is talking about in that the
the actual the the need for it wasn't
demonstrable so in terms of crime rate
in terms of of positioning it just
wasn't necessary so I think that that is
the it's the it's the policy framework
that is actually
preventing the return of that CCTV
camera so I think have and and I I did
look at the policy at that time and and
understood that to to to be what it
means councelor Wing I think David it's
all governed by gdpr as well so I mean
there are huge penalties it's all sort
of reversed so that the the person
operating the system uh the information
that's collected and the person that's
operating the system there's clear
guidance of what you can do and what you
can't do with the information you gather
so I feel quite confident that that the
council's doing all the due dilig
diligence necessary to uh operate a safe
system yeah I agree councelor cup I just
wanted to Echo what councelor Wing has
said and and I think that um I'm
certainly comfortable with the process
of the council was undertaking uh with
the CCTV and the procedures that are in
place I think are sound and obviously
it's it's policy compliant and that's
the most important thing um I I
appreciate that with these things there
there is sometimes a a need or a a
caution to to overp but I don't think
this is uh necessary because the
policies are in place to make sure uh
processes followed
correctly okay thank
you okay me to thank Mr gtis and anybody
doesn't realize the new memb here he is
our enforcement and multi- agency task
force manager so thank you for coming
along and and potention new report we'll
send that off to Cabinet okay moving on
to item nine uh the purchase of 24 Homes
at tothill Street Minster for affordable
event I've had a a declaration of
interest from councelor Pacman who is
going to leave us for five
minutes
and I call on Miss Jackson to present
her update thank you um the council has
recently approved an accelerated
affordable rented housing development
program of at least 400 new homes
constructed or acquired by
2027 officers were contact contacted by
BDW homes barretts who are required to
deliver 24 new affordable homes as part
of their development at to Hill Street
Minster this requirement is set out in
the section 106 obligations for the
development they have been unable to
secure an affordable housing provider to
deliver these homes the capital cost for
the 24 homes is 3.2 million and 50k for
Associated costs paragraph 2.5 of my
report shows the cash def cash flow
deficit from year one of 3.99k with a
break even point in year
15 as the homes have been designed as
affordable homes in the planning consent
and section 106 agreement they have been
designed specifically for that purpose
and accordingly are considered
appropriate for the HRA in line with the
needs of the households on the council's
register of those living and for those
living in temp accommodation there is a
significant level of Need for one beds
as well as for larger family homes
the unit size for this development are 8
times one bed units and 16 time two bed
units it is proposed that the new homes
are let in accordance with the council's
adopted allocations
policy thank
you okay thank you members any questions
for M Jackson councilor
Ghana all thanks just a well a
confirmation really these homes in Tot
Hill Street that this is a new
development isn't it that hasn't
actually started yet so this is from the
planning consent that was given at
planning committee in June of this year
yeah okay so I just wanted to clarify
that so normally what happens I believe
is that the development
um the
development uh is completed and while
it's being completed the developer looks
to to find a a um Housing Association to
take them on and when they can't take
them on they come back to us to say we
haven't found anyone for it we give you
some money or in this case but so have
they they've gone through that whole
process of looking since June not found
anyone CU one point is that's quite
concerning that it looks like housing
associations aren't looking to take any
affordable homes on um my other issue
here is because I remember this planning
application so this isn't necessarily an
issue for you I don't think but it's an
issue for planning because I've just
been double cheing this so This planning
application was the reserved matters for
phase one of the development there to
deliver
133 of the 214 homes being built
and when we heard this at planning
committee I'm on the planning committee
with one of one or two others here I
think the we the pl the report
stated that 30% of the affordable of
these homes would be affordable that
equated to 40 homes that would be
affordable units now of those 70% would
be for rent that's
28 and the then the 30% for shared
ownership that's 12 so it seems since
the planning consent was given in June
and we agreed 28 for
rent that's now been turned into 24 so
we've lost four affordable homes for ren
do do you do you happen to know what's
happened to them that it seems like
they've been Lost in Translation now
whether that means there are
now 16 shared ownership then I guess
that one of that that could be
considered fair enough but I mean now as
we're all aware our need is for more
affordable homes for rent
so I it's not as I say I don't think
it's necessarily for you but it would be
I would like to know what's happened to
those four homes that could have been
added to our our house housing stock and
been offered to rent for people on the
housing list they they seem to have been
lost I mean I I won't make any um
political points about um affordable
homes being lost and developers coming
back and and um Chang in their
agreements yeah so if I can just come
back on that so yeah you're absolutely
right um no RPS are delivering anything
less than probably 100 units on sites at
the moment they're not interested in
delivering section 106 sites because
they don't get any Grant from homes
England which we have fed back to homes
England so that's why and um as you know
barretts are quite active in thanet at
the moment they're kind of um you know
doing the Hae Road site as well so um
yes we have seen evidence that they've
tried to contact RPS and nobody is
interested and I have also spoken to RPS
separately as well and with regards to
the four units I will confirm that with
um Ian livson and come back to you on
that we have they won't been lost
there'll be a
something you have more you have more
confidence in some of the developers
than I do any opportunity to lose
affordable homes seems to be taken thank
you councelor
Davis hi Ashley and uh as you know I
welcome anything that uh removes people
from our housing list uh
removes re relieves people from being on
the housing L let's say um I do have a
couple of questions and it may again not
be for yourself cuz you're implementing
a policy here but there's a couple of
concerns and I know they're shared by
some of my colleagues who are not
necessarily in the chamber or are um we
have this accelerated policy to deliver
400 homes over a 4-year period in four
or five months I think we're up to 70
oddd so far it is a peaky time in the
market and things um there's just
concern that because of the cost of
borrowing and so on at the moment and I
know the Matrix shows them coming into
wiping their face after 15 years should
we really be you know at the pace we're
at because you know we're so we're
actually ahead of policy effectively or
is there a good reason because what
concerns me a bit is for example the
report says that uh barretts came to the
council um thank you for confirming that
you know Housing Association and
alternative providers had been contacted
cuz there's a there is a a risk factor
there which is you know it' be quite
easy for them to come along and the and
the tail to start wagging the dog oh we
can't find anyone we've got our way with
the planning application but now again
it works the for the time being at the
moment and if I say it's absolutely
Paramount that we get people out of
temporary accommodation you'll know
exactly what I mean I'm sure um but I do
question the haste and I think there's
concerns about you know whether we could
be getting better value out of this the
other thing by the way this isn't built
yet we've got sites like Peg Bay View
which is uh don't know if it's Town and
Country or somewhere but sites like that
that have got 80 they've gone 100%
affordable should we perhaps not be
prior prioritizing talking to people
like that before we take on stuff being
built on green green sites even though
they're
allocated okay so the um yeah I
appreciate that there has been a number
of sites that I've come I think I've
come to every on probably since
September um to bring a site this is
this is the last one at the moment um
these are sites that um have
been sort of been brewing for you know
for a good six to sort of 12 months we
knew they couldn't get um they were kind
of at their L at the end of their tether
trying to find a provider so um yeah I
agree
um we're certainly not in competition
with any
RPS absolutely not I will only step in
at the last minute if if I would much
rather that town of country delivered it
or robit or anyone like that it's um
yeah we are the last resort to be honest
we're not an we're not act I'm not
actively rounding everything up there
these are just coming to me saying I
don't know what else to do what can we
do um so I don't have any other sites in
the pipeline to come forward for now so
yeah I do app appreciate it's actually
been 92 since July um so it is a lot and
obviously on top of that we've got our
development as well and so you know sort
of in about six months we'll be about
150 it's excellent to hear in terms of
relieving the pressure on the housing
Ashley so please don't misunderstand and
and and I think you know from what I've
said before I'm a much bigger fan of
producing it ourselves than having a
third party in the in the mix but if
that's the case and by the way a couple
of the deals do appear to be incredible
value so congratulate you on what you
settled on there um but thank you for
clarifying it as I say cuz a lot of
people have been concerned that we're
just diving headlong down down a path
thank you Council
V yeah I'd just like to congratulate um
you on this one as well um I I think I
may have missed the section where you're
talking about the actual the costs and
the rate of the the deal itself which is
what councelor Davis um just referred to
so I'm assuming my first question was
we're really happy with the deal we've
got for these
properties yeah so um yeah I work with
Finance colleagues um we we run the
figures through sort of a business case
um they kind of give me a maximum that I
can go to and yeah we negotiate on that
basis and this has been in line with the
other ones that we've
delivered thank you um and do we have a
timeline
on again referring to the the previous
question we've got 96 properties
essentially that are that are kind of up
and running or ready to go do we have a
timeline on when we can actually start
to expect to be getting that value back
cuz obviously or getting that rent in
because obviously the sooner we get that
rent in the sooner it starts to pay for
itself and and we can all be very
pleased with ourselves yeah so the only
one that's currently um due for
completion soon and handed over to us is
the Spitfire green site which is the
barretts one h Road um all the other
ones I've bought haven't even started
yet so um Reading Street Northwood Road
um and this one obviously um this one's
due to start on site in the new year so
we're looking at a 12- month build at
least councilor Wing uh I was also on
that the planning the planning committee
when when this application came in and
one of the one of the main concerns we
had was uh the the issues with water
provision and sewage provision on site
and and I think uh it was agreed that
that there would be no hookup allowed
until there was some sort of uh
arrangement with Southern water to
ensure that that hookup could be safely
made given the uh extreme situation of
sewage and waste in Minster and at the
weatherly's uh treatment plant so
certainly that's something I'd want us
to look into CU we don't want houses
with no hookup to a system uh that that
definitely needs looking into also uh
can we guarantee that that we that those
houses are are delivered to the same
standard and quality as every single
housing on that housing estate the last
planning uh planning committee I was on
and it wasn't this application I was
really shocked to see the social housing
squashed in the worst place on the site
smaller units clearly creating division
between uh The Haves and the hav nots on
that site I you know I'd much rather I
think we'd all much rather see that that
people in Social social housing were
were given the same quality housing and
that will actually disperse so that they
felt part of part of the whole Housing
Development rather than a you know the
the the the terrible bit in the corner
uh and how many of these units would be
disability friendly or or age proofed
and are there any
expectations uh to put energy saving in
energy solar panels on the roof gray
water harvesting all the things that can
help people on low income sustain living
in a in a rented
accommodation so just with the um I'll
check the uh the water thing with you
I'll come back to you on that as well um
just with regards to the uh where the
units are on the site I um they're
obviously that's all laid out in the
section 106 and part of the schedule my
team are consulted on that and we always
ask for it to be
integrated um but sometimes the sites
the units are smaller so they will put
all the smaller unit together and then
that's how we always end up with the you
know they're always in one bit but we do
encourage them to be pepper potted that
does also create a bit of a problem with
management as well the RPS don't like
them pepper potty because it's all over
the site so works both ways but we
always like it
integrated
um what was the other question
disability disability yes so all the
yeah there is a requirement for the
units to B M3 but and I'll confirm that
with you as well with with regards to
the other points and also potentially
put so build houses without Sol toce the
biggest cost yeah biggest cost to to
anybody whether you're renting or you
own your own
property sorry so our units that we're
doing in our new bill program will be as
near near to Net Zero as we can get them
we they're going to be all singing and
all dancing you know they're going to be
kind of epc's a at least um yeah with
regards to these yeah they haven't got I
mean the Spitfire green ones they were
quite far down they were already nearly
built by time we bought them that's how
desperate they were to get rid of them
um but we you know we are working with
our RPS to encourage them as much as we
can um that the Town and Country site at
pole Lane they're all MMC they've all
got air source heat pumps solar panels
so they've done it there they just need
to see that it works so they do it
elsewhere thank you any further
questions Mr Jackson the last meeting
when you came and we discussed the the
five houses at ring Street I think I
expressed some concern that you said
that developers had contacted you
because they couldn't offload their
affordable housing now you're saying
that this company has now approached you
cuz they can't unload 24 and I think you
said before it's cuz it was such a small
number at reading street now we're up to
24 and they can't offload them and now
you're saying it's 100 so with your head
of planning hat on does this mean that
developers can't deliver um their
affordable housing on any projects that
are under 300 units so is it time to
start looking at um putting those size
of developments on hold if developers
can't um deliver their their their
affordable
housing I I don't think so because I
think at the moment it's just the market
so um there are specifically housing
associations who like smaller ones and
they like the uh the reading street ones
but at this moment in time it wasn't
right for them so for example West Kent
housing have picked up eight and 12 that
sort of thing so it's definitely not a
no um but the homes England Grant makes
it really difficult for it for it to be
viable for them so that's also what
we're LOB being as well yeah I think
it's concerning when you say that they
won't pick up anything under 100 now I
think that's concerning with I mean I've
lost count of how many applications are
now for for Mass development in thanet
that that we know they're not going to
do that okay thank you so members uh any
recommendations for this report to
cabinet and that's a no so I thank Mr
Jackson for coming along and presenting
their report okay item 10 hope we get Mr
councelor Pacman back
here
okay moving on to item 10 which is the
review of the overview and scru panel
work program for 2324 uh do members have
any questions to ask or comments to make
regarding the work
program silence okay I know that on the
we got one subject left on subjects that
were put forward and that's the parking
review I did speak to councelor Keane
before the meeting because I think there
some I know Penny's probably might have
something to say there's some holdups
for the moment but she said she was
happy that it would all be sorted out by
Jan January meeting which is 16th of
January for her to come along and
present that report on the parking
review so Penny have you got anything
you could like to tell
us I will let Mike give the update if
that's okay CU he's the last person that
spoke to our procurement team is that
okay Mike thank
you um yes so in terms of the the
parking strategy work we will be in a
position to award that um very soon I'm
not going to give you an exact date cuz
CU cuz I might get it wrong but uh the
the procurement process is nearly at the
end and we'll be we in a position to
award that as soon as we have awarded
the contract we'll be looking for the
consultant you know we'll be working
with the consultant to um put out the
dates for the public engagement because
I know that that's the bit that
everyone's particularly interested in so
I think we'll be working to uh provide
those dates as as quickly as
possible okay excellent so if I can ask
Charles to invite councilor Kean to or
pencil in for January the 16th to do a
cabinet presentation on the parking
review
okay and all members agree with that
yeah okay and council
do sorry same topics like the off topic
moving ahead um we mentioned earlier
about lack of uh lack of update on
leveling up and so on with again without
with or without Gant charts individuals
or anything else we were promised
regular updates at each meeting can I uh
suggest that we uh chase that up and
also um with regard to uh cabinet the
other night it was mentioned that
working groups have been established
amongst officers for uh with regard to
Bringing forward the implementations
which Grant Thornton recommended to do
immediately uh what scrutiny is there of
the work of those to ensure that that
the grant Thornton's recommendations are
implemented do we get to uh have input
on that or could we check that out
please because it's an area that
requires
scrutiny okay I mean with with regards
to the the report I will keep on to the
director who's in charge of that and
hopefully for our next meeting in
January that there will be a report that
we can all see I think it's important
that we um hear what's going on I think
we were told by masasu that we were told
about the implementation of the new town
team or whatever it's going to be called
that that how that was going to be set
up and who was going to be on it etc etc
so I will keep on to it and hopefully
January we'll have something to to talk
about okay thank you cuz for the record
we still know wiser about how the
certain members are being appointed to
that uh my I finally got a response from
the leader and it completely avoided the
key question so uh which we'll follow
through on but I think it's important
that we know where we are because
otherwise we're going to be three months
in from the announcement of that board
and absolutely nowhere forward so I can
assure you and Charles will agree with
me that I have asked and then hopefully
we'll find out soon C
agree apart from the major topics which
I understand we can only do one at a
time because of Officer support uh we
also asked for three smaller reports
from officers on on spe I can't remember
what they were now but what why aren't
we getting
them okay so the bin was one of them
parking review is the other one and I
can't remember what the other one was
but I think we've had those Now parking
review was the last one but then I did
say in the New Year we'd look at other
other subjects to add to the list we had
a list and we've gone through the list
in the last few months so so get come to
the near year the January 16th I'll ask
for some new topics and we we'll work
from there but the scrutiny review
councelor Brer is undertaken is coming
to an end I will say that he has asked
for to open the next meeting which is at
the end of the month open to all members
to can come along I know a few of you
have already expressed an interest to do
that and if you do want to come along to
to to to Council of Rich's meeting on
the tourism review then please uh let
Charles know send you an invite to that
meeting Council chman yeah one topic
that and we agreed to look at was fly
tipping and abandoned vehicles um I'm
not sure if that works I've not seen any
work being taken SL Caravans yeah I will
that will well I will add that for for
I'm not sure when the meeting is after
Janu then we we'll look at whichever
cabinet it seems to be like hundreds of
abandoned Caravans Caravans and cars
sorts trailers and all okay yeah that's
can I will definitely add that and then
there's just one thing that I would like
to add to the list if if possible is how
our residents um access Council services
so we have the
um Gateway which sits there pretty much
empty on a daily basis and a lot of
feedback from our residents are they
would like to have face Toof face
Services maybe not full time but um it's
something I'd like to review and have a
look at so bringing back maybe face Toof
face Services through housing or through
um through civa really cuz there are uh
people like Council attacks and and
benefit support so um you know back in
the day used be a to go into the gateway
and have a have a chat with somebody um
so yeah sure yeah I mean if you've
looked at the the forward plan I think
there's some something happening with
East Kent services and it's the the way
the service has been developed is
changing so maybe it's something will
happen there but I I'll definitely make
a note that and see what we can do okay
anybody else got anything to say on
that okay so we just uh asked to agree
the work program which we've done and we
move on to item 11 which is the forward
plan exempt cabinet decision list uh
unless there's something from the plan
the panel wish to discuss then we ask to
note the
report okay no report it concludes the
business for this evening's meeting I
declare this meeting closed uh thank you
all for coming thank you your officers
cabinet members and uh officers from
democratic services for helping us out
this evening the live stream of this
meeting we now end thank you very
much